philippe muray re bonjour merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors taxer davantage les plus riches
est ce que ça vous semble être une bonne
idée
oui je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
idée puisque on voit qu'il ya un abîme
qui se creuse par exemple en france
entre les pauvres et les riches
on a avec la crise du coc vide on va
passer de 9 millions de pauvres à 10
millions de pauvres il ya même déjà un
million de pauvres en plus selon les
associations caritatives on a 20 % des
français qui ne mangent pas à leur faim
et ça ça fait longtemps que ça dure
puisque on avait 8 millions de repas aux
restos du coeur
en 1985 on en a 130 millions aujourd'hui
et pendant ce temps effectivement les
fortunes des plus riches augmentent sans
arrêt sur les dix dernières années on a
appris par la banque suisse ubs que les
fortunes des milliardaires français sont
passés de 80 milliards d'euros à 400
milliards d'euros x situation par 5 qui
est colossal
donc on a des riches qui sont plus en
plus riches des pauvres dans les pays
occidentaux de plus en plus pauvres et
des riches de moins en moins taxés donc
c'est une situation qui n'est acceptable
ayez auquel il faut remédier après il
faut bien voir quelle est la source de
ces inégalités et cette source c'est la
mondialisation économique et la
mondialisation financière c'est à dire
c'est le libre échange et la préférence
pour la finance parce que je pense qu'il
faut quand même souligner que les
pauvres ne demande pas l'aumône ils
veulent juste un travail pour gagner
dignement leur vie alors que les
milliardaires malheureusement ils sont
opposés puisqu'ils profitent de la
mondialisation financière qui les
enrichit et qui en même temps mais les
pauvres chômage donc voilà le dilemme
dans lequel on aime mais il faut bien
revenir à la source des inégalités et
pas seulement faire de la charité en
reprenant un peu honte action pour leur
donner aux pauvres
alors on parle ici de recommandation de
la part de
du fmi c'est simplement des idées un
taxer les plus riches davantage ça
semble compliqué à mettre en place pour
tous les pays du monde
oui c'est impossible quand on veut faire
une réforme mondiale il faudrait que
tous les pays soient d'accord
ce qui rend la chose totalement
improbable on voit bien les difficultés
dans les po les 27 pays de l'union
européenne de se mettre d'accord et
encore ils sont proches culturellement
puis l'autre problème qu'en mars et que
cette mondialisation économique et
financière le libre-échange fait que les
entreprises peuvent localiser les
bénéfices où elles le veulent
par exemple dans les paradis fiscaux
proche de la france l'irlande des pays
bas et l'irlande
c'est ce qui arrive souvent les recettes
fiscales sont pliés et de l'autre côté
l'absence de contrôle des mouvements de
capitaux en fait fait que les plus
riches peuvent placer leurs capitaux
là où il ya la moindre fiscalité donc
ses complexes dans le monde de la
mondialisation financière et de livres
et de libre échange et donc il faut
remédier à ses causes là si on veut
remédier à ce problème d'inégalité de
faible croissance économique alors le
fmi parle également de choix proposé aux
pays de faire des choix notamment en
investissant dans les emplois de demain
est ce que quelque part ça veut dire
qu'on va abandonner certains secteurs
non non non certainement pas il faut
garder tous ses secteurs les pays les
plus puissants les plus riches comme le
japon l'allemagne les états unis
essayent de garder le maximum de
secteurs
par contre il faut se développer dans de
nouveaux secteurs ça c'est clair
mais avec quel argent en fait il n'y a
pas d'argent et là c'est leur goût moi
je trouve qu'il ya une grande hypocrisie
dans cette crise puisqu'il ya un plan de
relance de la finance de 1000 milliards
d'euros par exemple en europe
c'est à dire que la banque centrale
européenne un prix 1000 milliards
d'euros de billets pour acheter des
actifs dans les marchés financiers et
fait remonter les marchés financiers qui
explose pareille aux états unis or
qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que les plans
de relance de l'économie réelle de ces
de ces filières de demain sont très très
faible a comparé ils sont très petits or
les 1000 milliards c'est pour les riches
et la partie très très faible c'est pour
tous les autres qui se partagent quelque
chose de très faibles il ya une vraie
hypocrisie là dedans alors le famille
incite aussi les gouvernements
investir dans la formation pour
justement préparer l ces fameuses emploi
de de demain c'est une recommandation
qui vous paraît salutaire
oui mais c'est la même rengaine ans puis
en fait depuis 15 ans il ya des gens
extrêmement bien formés qui n'ont pas
d'emploi en france qui ne trouvent pas
d'emploi
on sait qu'on à 6,8 millions de chômeurs
et c'est pas dû aux problèmes du système
des gens qui sont mal formés je connais
des gens très bien formés qui n'ont pas
d'emploi
c'est dû au fait qu'on a six millions
8,2 personnes inscrites à pôle emploi et
donc c'est extrêmement difficile de
trouver du travail parce que le système
de libre échange et de mondialisation
financière ne crée pas d'emplois et crée
plutôt du chômage
merci beaucoup philippe maurer d'avoir
été avec nous cet après midi je rappelle
que vous êtes économiste merci beaucoup